this morning on the dish we take you to Los
Alamos California and while it's a small town
it's now on the world culinary map thanks to
a husband and wife Duo and their acclaimed
restaurant Jamie wax had a chance to visit and
got a taste Jamie good morning good morning
Michelle and a taste is Right Bells is located
along California's Central Coast about an hour
north of Santa Barbara but while it's off the
beaten path enthusiastic diners have certainly
managed to find it it's earned glowing reviews
and earned Chef Daisy Ryan a coveted Michelin star
the term Farm to Table is overused in the
restaurant business but it's an actual
description of Chef Daisy Ryan's daily commute
Daisy this is where you start your morning
here at Findlay Farms the Finley surprised me
every day what's surprising you today lately
we've had these really beautiful blackberries I
mean largest I've ever seen truly uh blackberries
that are grown here on Family Farm yeah they're
pretty awesome really good awesome right so good
that fresh produce from California's Central Coast
it is also Central to the dishes served by Chef
Ryan and her husband Greg at their French
inspired Bistro Bells booney tureen tartar
serves a Cuisine they jokingly refer to as
French it's French and Ranch yes yeah exactly
it's as rural as can be and what's fresh but
it also has a little little touch of French in
it it is a good descriptor for what we do because
they're hopefully is a perceived level of finesse
and sophistication and maybe a little bit more
fine dining in the way that we do things however
there is still this Simplicity um not necessarily
rustic but something that is not quite so Pomp and
Circumstance about the food and we got to sample
some of it starting with escargot cooked with
parsley pernot garlic and butter this is the
most I will say herbaceous and garlicky like
in the best way escargot I ever had my whole life
thank you I can't wait to hear again and I'm gonna
soak all the rest of it up with this bread also
on the table uni crepe a Santa Barbara sea urchin
on layered crepes with Creme Fresh topped with
caviar this is a perfect bite I mean this really
is and this is how everybody starts their meal at
dinner we do a small bite of this steak crusted
with peppercorn and accompanied with fruits
we talk about it being our connection and Nod
towards the way that we started this restaurant
in it being a very traditional French Bistro
gorgeously medium rare let's take a pois at its
best that is unbelievable Dell's Farm Fresh Salad
and for dessert champagne moose this is so
beautifully delicate and fluffy but but also
salty not just sweet but salty and that little
bit of salt brings out these figs like crazy it's
delicious the restaurant has helped transform
the quaint town of Los Alamos that's especially
important to Chef Daisy a native of the area who
set out on a non-traditional career path starting
in culinary school and then in Hospitality for
the legendary Thomas Keller and Danny Meyer
I loved cooking I like the high intensity of it
there is an artistic element it's athletic in many
ways so I always intended on cooking but I had an
instructor at the CIA that said hey you're really
good in the dining room and per se is looking for
team members in the dining room it was at per se
that she met her partner in life and in business
at the heart of this is a love story a love story
about home love story about food and a love story
between two people yeah and somebody asked me like
what is your concept and Greg and I kind of look
at each other and go well our it's our life you
know it is it is just the things that we love and
and are just really excited that other people love
those things too and it's just it's worked out I
think that's why we feel it when we're diners here
the pair bonded in New York then moved together
to La Austin and eventually back to the Santa Ynez
Valley largely because of the encouragement of
the chef parents I have a great relationship with
my mom and dad they're really the reason that I
became interested in food and wine and restaurants
and my dad is a very ambitious person and he's
like well let's just buy a restaurant let's
do something let's make it happen it felt like a
place that we could actually make a difference and
make an impact and they have definitely done that
Bells has become a dining destination and Ryan has
garnered accolades along the way including
being named food and Wine's best new chef
and being awarded a coveted Michelin star do you
remember the moment you found out yeah you become
um like emotional just because it's not something
that we ever really searched for it's not anything
that we were ambitious about um but that someone
decided to acknowledge something that you did
um on on your own terms you think Ritz
crackers both Daisy and Greg say they're
anxious to use what they've learned to help
others in the industry this restaurant is is
kind of what we this is what we have to say
everything else that might come our way or
that we decide that we want to try and do is
through collaboration of others and hopefully
uh offering them an opportunity to give them
a chance to say something as well and for Chef
Daisy Ryan that goal is especially personal do
you hope that you're an inspiration for young
women who want to run a kitchen sure I hope to set
a standard and be a leader for for younger people
so we have a game here from they have one of
the greatest wine lists in the country this is
from the region from the Santa Ynez Valley oh
my gosh and yes cheers cheers cheers and uh I
will say Los Alamos was a food destination
without bells but they really came in but
there are some other great places to go it's a
tiny town where you can spend days just having
a great time and you said they're open on
Monday yes they're open on Mondays because
all the chefs from Los Angeles and the region
come to eat on their night off really yes that's
the truth they are a Chef's Restaurant what a
sign of respect absolutely always love hearing
the stories about when they find out they're
they have a Michelin style it's great yeah